[Music]
Libyan warlord Khalifa Hrothgar says the
fighting will continue a ceasefire
called by Russia and Turkey has been
rejected and half DARS vowed to take
control of the capital Tripoli has been
renewed Libyan Arab armed forces will
continue to target the enemy by air and
land moving forward and spread its
control of new forces in all areas from
the capital from the west of Cert to the
outskirts of Misrata international
concern is now growing across the region
half Dharma with Italy's Prime Minister
Giuseppe contain Rome hoping to stir
support from the European Union
then there's Russia and Turkey which
support rivals on the ground Ankara has
begun to point troops in support of the
UN recognized government and by turning
down the ceasefire half dark could be
pushing away Russia one of his main
allies
fighting has escalated between half dars
Libyan National Army and the
internationally recognized government in
Tripoli attempts to take control of the
capital have fallen short but half DARS
forces have gained ground especially in
the coastal city of cert mr. Witt hanim
will continue to liberate Libya from the
clutches of evil
we're fighting terrorism at the state
and world level Libya is strategically
important it has the largest oil
reserves in africa the country's
location along the Mediterranean coast
has become a gateway for African
migrants fleeing to Europe
Tunisia's president ke Syed met with
France's foreign minister to warn about
the potential consequences of the
conflict technically open Egyptians fo
together with my European and Egyptian
colleagues we are highlighting the risks
of an escalation in Libya it would
threaten to destabilize the entire
region in the market to the Suhail
leaders from the European Union are
banding together warning that Libya
could become a second Syria if a
ceasefire isn't to reach soon Katya
Lucas of a young al Jazeera